tu es la plus grosse perte de fric alors
le truc t'a coûté le plus chaud ça
dépanneuse
je pense que
je pense que là on a été bien ce que
maintenant je vais te faire un le plus
le moins
tu es prêt le morceau de toi que tu
préfères le morceau de musique la
chanson
[Rires]
je pense que c'est la belle vie la
chanson de toi que tu détestes la
chanson monsieur cannibale ah oui c'est
pas moi
Internet plus gros succès de disques et
de ça même été je crois la chanson qui a
le plus rapportée d'argent à sa scène
une année
et ça faisait comment là Monsieur
cannibale
je ne veux pas mourir
c'était une chanson qui avait faite pour
Carlos avant toi
c'est dommage ça aurait été fait pour
lui le plus grand moment de ta vie
grands moments de ma vie de ma naissance
j'ai des tartes et le pire moment de ta
vie
pire moment de ma vie
j'ai eu un
moment donné
un problème de santé très important on
peut le dire ou pas cachée était
envisageable
quand on dit que Sacha Distel est très
en forme
oui qui n'avait rien à voir l'un avec
l'autre mais tout le monde il paraît
alors
tout le monde fait dans sa vie il se
déclare ils se déclare pas
de peau pas de pot dans la peau
dis-moi ce que tu as eu beaucoup de
courage parce que il y a toute une
époque où tu disais rien à personne
étalé de Villejuif à l'Olympia fusée de
la chimio à Villejuif l'Olympia le soir
et tout ça des centaines de gens
malheureusement qui ont ça et ils
chantent tous les soirs
gratuits
le plus mauvais le plus mauvais moment
pour avoir la question c'était justement
quand la première fois on m'a dit bon
voilà ce que vous avez et on m'a
convoqué d'urgence à l'hôpital pour
faire des des analyses et je me suis
retrouvé sur le périph tu vois allant à
l'hôpital Antoine des clercs à Clamart
et je voyais des des mecs au volant de
leur gros camion qui râlent tu vois
parce qu'on leur a pas payé ceci ils ont
pas fait cela et ils sont
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont heureux s'ils
savaient ça c'était des moments tu vois
je me souviens ce cliché là ta maman
très désagréable j'en ai bien sorti dis
donc
celle-là dis-moi et l'avion l'avion qui
est tombé c'était dans un avion un petit
avion de location
c'est le seul jour de ta vie où tu as
été en retard à un gars là il paraît
j'ai même pas fait le gars c'est le seul
que j'ai manqué
il paraît que ta femme dans l'avion
aurait cité son acte de contrition au
dernier moment elle m'a dit viens viens
d'être cesser le pilote j'étais à côté
elle derrière là elle vient de quatre
places et dernier moment après avoir
volé pendant trois heures pour brûler
l'essence pour risquer d'exploser si par
hasard on touche quelque chose
en atterrissant il me dit vient derrière
il y a c'est ça les femmes mourir la
main dans la main mais dis non imbécile
c'est la place du mort c'est pas là je
suis passé derrière et il y avait le
moteur à la place j'avais dit ça c'est
il a tapé un moment non
tension au milieu des trucs
de fric
je pense que c'est un une publicité que
j'ai faite pour une télévision en
Angleterre qui était
je vendais aux toilettes elle avait une
autre toilette je vendais pas j'étais
l'image
de l'autre toilette c'est une ligne de
toilette un petit peu comme Fabergé
alors on m'avait demandé de d'être leur
présenter alors on a fait le monde
entier avec ça
avec une autre toilette que tu as gagné
le plus d'argent si c'est pas malheureux
tu es la plus grosse perte de fric alors
le truc ça coûté le plus chaud
je pense que
je pense que là on a été bien secouru
je crois que c'est probablement cette
histoire de comédie musicale justement
87 et dans laquelle j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup mais je le referai ce que tu as
le plus sexy en toi
avec toutes les gonzesses qui s'est tapé
il doit bien avoir quelque chose à mon
avis
ce que tu as de moins sexy toi
[Musique]
je
je sais pas qu'est-ce que j'ai
Philippe labroque j'avais des mains
d'assassins ah
mais pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu